so pretty i actually want to ask you
this on camera yeah what's up so
recently we put out a video in regards
to like my hesitancy with you know
getting vaccinated or whatnot
and uh you know caused some issues with
youtube and us
and uh
made me think about it when you cover
certain topics on this platform
immediately what ends up happening is
that you start to get de-rinked meaning
your videos get shown to less people
which you know then affects your revenue
stream it affects your ability to grow
and protects a lot of different things
and we've been feeling it for a couple
months right there's a reason why our
click-through rate is the same that is
but the impressions which is how many
videos people get shown to has reduced
and it's been like a confusing thing so
i'm in talks with youtube but it made me
think like yo should we avoid these kind
of topics or these things that we don't
want to talk about but the truth is
we've also gotten here by talking about
all the things that we want by
discussing the things that we want so
we're gonna catch one too a little bit a
little bit for me this is my thoughts on
it my personal opinion i would just like
to cover what we want to cover and if it
gets shown to less people it is what it
is we kind of got to eat that but that's
what i think is better do you think we
should segment our content to just
include certain things and maybe keep
that covered stuff for other platforms
i mean we could at the end of the day
this is our bread and butter
it doesn't mean that we don't have an
opinion about some stuff i'm not i'm i
don't want to close i don't want to be
close in my close-minded to everything
that we want to talk about like be like
you know what we're not going to talk
about it because we just want to be
about the money that's not what we've
been about and that's not what it is you
know you have to ask yourself the
question is it worth it whenever we
cover it's not everything that is cov
it's worth
being covered yeah some things we just
don't want to cover because we're not
interested because we're not interested
but after that there's like the toll
that it takes on the other videos that
we really want to put out there yeah so
that's what a question we have to ask
pros and cons
good or bad yeah
is it worth it is it worth it let me
work it
i put my thing down flipping and reverse
it yeah it's a tough question i think
for me we never really got into it for
the money so i suppose the decision is
pretty simple for us from a principal
standpoint but it is unfortunate because
you know the principle aside we do want
folks to be able to see the videos you
know and i'm not even talking about like
complete strangers i'm talking about our
own subscribers the fact that you guys
stopped start to see it less and less
despite having the bell checked off
that's also a fortune to me so it's just
some of the things that youtube
sometimes does that makes you realize
like hell you can't keep yourself to one
platform which is why we could put the
videos on if we put the video on the
platform we'll only show them to our
patreon we get deranked still
potentially yeah it's a complicated one
but anyways we are the one we're trying
to figure out a way to kind of get the
best of both worlds about the world
mike tyson real quick
is that since this platform is moving so
much and all the time if there's really
no real question there's really no real
answer to that question no because we
don't do safe stuff so because of that
you know you recognize that you're
expendable that's the reality yeah so
anyways for that reason alone i think
that's why you know we're going to call
on you guys to help out if you guys can
hit the bell button if you're already
subscribed if you're not make sure you
do but if you guys want to help us out
make sure to like every video you know
all doing all that little stuff helps us
boost us up in the algorithm so that we
don't have to deal with this stuff all
the time but it's unfortunate it's
unfortunate that we even measured
content that doesn't necessarily spread
information but just shares a different
perspective that
just comes from personal experience even
that kind of stuff is is now becoming
unacceptable and year of trusted sources
which actually can't be trusted per se
even that video is not going to get as
much use watch no no even this one you
know like the last video i'm gonna tell
you something
it had the highest click-through rate of
any video we've ever done
but the impressions was in the bottom
third
and if you don't know what click-through
rate click-through rate is like when
people see it how often do they click
through it we have something between 25
and 30 percent if you don't know how i'm
saying that is most videos hover between
11 to 15 it was double that crazy high
but the impressions was mad low because
youtube didn't want to recommend it to
folks which is you know how they operate
and then i got contacted losing some
issues but for us it's for me it's
important because it's like if it's on
my mind i like talking about it and if
you want to help us out you guys want to
make sure that we get through that
definitely make sure you hit the likes
and stuff like that we are going to
start posting more exclusive videos just
on patreon alone so if you guys want to
be able to support pre setting up his
own personal podcast that's going to be
available through the patreon on video
so be on the lookout for that but uh
we're definitely making a lot of content
to make it worthwhile for you guys so if
you want to support us and keep the
channel going always help us out that
way but yeah i mean even beyond that if
you guys just take the time to hit the
like and comment that also helps a lot
so i want to make it worth it for you
guys i suppose but we wanted to have
like a transparent talk to so many of
you were asking us about the video and
i'm like it's unfortunate man it's just
part of being on this platform i don't
regret the things i said but uh
definitely the platform makes it very
difficult to say all the things that you
want but you know that's how we got here
so that's how we'll keep going forward
is there anything else
so just want to let you guys know you
guys can let us know your thoughts but
yeah they really don't want folks
talking about this unless you uh say
what they say
you know it doesn't matter how right you
are it doesn't matter how many studies
you you cite there's more you know how
many things like you can get banned for
saying the very same things that they
see on cnn or cnbc but you were not
seeing the nursing home you seen it come
up there's a new controversial study if
you come out and say there's a new
controversy you could get that's how
crazy things have gone so it's just
unfortunate that we can't have these
talks casually but that's the era we
live in so gotta make it work
[Music]
the
[Applause]
[Music]
i